ever try so hard for something but it
feels like you're ice-skating uphill
like you're doomed to fail like
something is against you like it's just
not meant to happen well now we know why
[Music]
The Adjustment Bureau now The Adjustment
Bureau when looking at it and seeing the
trailer I was like that's either gonna
be great or it's gonna be I still
hold to that but just embarrass the
story of Matt Damon and Emily Blunt they
meet up and they have a really strong
connection they like each other only
thing is there's a bureau of people that
keep people on the past they're supposed
to be on it's just part of the plan and
Matt Damon and Emily Blunt being
together does not go along with that
plan so anytime there's a really cool
and unique movie that does not become a
success it should be now we know why now
this movie really interested me because
it really touched on something that is
absolutely real which is ultimately
people have a void they need to fill it
with something so they aspire to be
great but most of the time when people
find someone and fall in love that void
is filled now so they don't need to
aspire to be great and this movie deals
with that fact because Matt Damon and
Emily Blunt are supposed to be great
people but they'll only do that if
they're not together because they'll be
content and in love and live comfortably
middle class not part of the plan so if
you want to be successful remain single
I've been saying this for years it
reminds me of my favorite monologue in
the show heroes where Linderman talks
about you can either have a life of
happiness or a life of meaning you
cannot have both I found that really
interesting because people are
absolutely like that I mean seriously
what would you do is it that cut and dry
yeah I know life and meaning totally and
after that it becomes a struggle of free
will of a guy trying to take the reins
of his destiny and then all-around
badass movie and then seeing him do that
like fight his fate and try to remain
one step ahead of these guys and
actually kind of outsmart them it was
like watching a really cool game of
chess battle of the brains always loved
that probably one of the more compelling
love stories that I've seen because
we've all felt like that we've all done
something and we're like why is this so
hard I just can't get this to work and
whatever it is it doesn't have to be
like a chick or a girlfriend or whatnot
it could be something simple like
setting up XM radio I swear to god it's
not meant to happen with me Adjustment
Bureau come on give me a break
I want my XM now Matt Damon was really
good in the movie Emily Blunt she was
awesome she was like this really cute
hot fun chick you really can't ask for
more I'm not saying I would give up a
life of meaning for that I'm saying I
would
be tempted and also what I liked is
these Adjustment Bureau guys they're
fallible they're not perfect they do
screw up in fact this whole thing
happened because one of them screwed up
I like that but I really liked it I
think everyone could connect with the
movie interesting premise it's well
acted I thought they were all great in
the movie and Terence Stamp is a really
cool monologue in the movie like Matt
Damon's like give us freewill we should
have freewill and Terence stamps like
you did have it and then Rome the Great
Depression World War One World War two
the nuke now we do it this way now much
better for everyone
can't argue but emily Blunt's so hot so
again The Adjustment Bureau I would say
I would buy this movie even on blu-ray
it was really exciting really intense in
parts but no one likes shot at anyone
it's like the most non violent thriller
that ever happened but it is definitely
worth a watch at least once it's one of
those date movies that you can take a
date to and you'll both love it it's a
dude movie that's a date movie that
happens once every few years
but if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more I'm not saying The
Adjustment Bureau wants you to I'm
saying they don't so fight that
[Music]